hometown boy you're here in the all-star
game in Chicago that must really feel
good it must be a special weekend for
you to be playing in this game in front
of your home yeah it feels good to be
back
play I says is it's memorable for me
just in the sense that I get to see my
friends and family again I mean I'm all
the way out of LA now so it's a long
flight for them to come out and see me
to be here and kind of be ambassador for
the city show these guys a great time do
stuff in the community it's been great
for me so far and I'm looking for the
rest of weekend was there a little bit
of a side eye to LeBron when you're
picking like you you know what's up
nothing he already knows I think I think
he already knew I jumped on him about
that he had to pick me first as I'm his
teammate and he gave us this leg bag but
I kind of had I did he was gonna figure
the boy all eyes on the NBA have
definitely been on you all the last few
weeks it feels to me like maybe your
team has even galvanized more since
Kobe's death was that something you all
sat and talked about like let's do this
for him I think everyone in the locker
room knows it every one of the
organization is something that doesn't
need to be talked about you know I think
we all came together and you know share
some of our best moments but we knew we
know that you know we wanna do is he
would be proud of us and we're gonna do
as much as we can to make him proud you
know
on the floor and off the floor as well
everything he stood for everything he
embodied we want to continue that legacy
with the Lakers organization are you
healing as a basketball family as a
Laker family it's tough I mean there's
there's nothing that you know can kind
of get over right away
you know especially in the Laker
organization he's touched so many people
in the organization that it's something
not something that you just get over
with get it over with you know we we we
see his numbers every day on the floor
and the facility we wait on our jerseys
and so it's something that we we don't
get away from and we don't want to get
away from me
we try to you know you know do that as
motivation if I power in go out and play
for him every night will you be at the
Memorial on Monday try to get back there
now to late Sunday hopefully if I can
our definite ossible well how old were
you all lift up his legacy and kind of
honor him this weekend I'm not sure if
you guys heard but the all-star team
LeBron is wearing number two well
everyone on LeBron scene was wearing to
it everyone Rana Stephens wear 24 to
kind of honor Kobe and gg
and so that's something special that the
league came came came up with and I
think there's something special for all
of us you know because so many guys have
been affected by Kobe and to honor his
legacy and they decide to wear the
numbers for him and his daughter and I
think that was a cool thing
it was so excited when you came to the
Lakers he wanted you there badly did you
guys have a good conversation about it
and how did that feel to know that Kobe
wanted you playing for that team we
didn't have a conversation about it but
I kind of expect the energy I mean you
know just it just feels good to you know
play for organization that you know he
played for you know kind of just help
carry on their legacy so there's a
pretty dope how are you gonna create a
potato-chip bring the bag out and then
not bring it down here and open it so we
can eat it don't watch my diet no I'll
make sure I give you a bag but you know
they're they're unbelievable uh you know
ruffles and I did a great job of you
know making that ship work so you know
I'm looking a lot of great with you so
I'm just I'm very excited tell me about
the flavor then and how you kind of came
up with I like spicy food I like spice
and so I like my almost all my jalapeno
I just wanna do jalapeno and they're
like well we got a kind of a SUP the
toolkit we already have a hot flavor
so they went it's in lime and said I
think it's a great combination so we
tried it and they work well together and
and we made it work I like that because
if I don't want the tortilla chip
I can have my potato chip walking chips
guac and potatoes exactly
[Music]